hello my dear students and welcome to
this week overview during this week we
are going to be talking about the soil
degradation and conservation so we are
going to be stared talking about the
erosion the process by which material
such as top soil is moved from one place
to another caused by natural processes
and human activities often occurs faster
than soil is formed depleting fertile
top soil crops trees and other plants
communities protect soil from
erosion so in conclusion erosion is the
movement of stuff like dirt from one
spot to another it happens because of
natural and things people do sometimes
it's quicker than soil can be made which
is not good because it takes away the
good Rich dirt from the top plants like
crops and trees help keep the soil safe
from erosion they act like a shield
making sure the dirt stays where it
should be this way the soil stays
healthy and can keep supporting plants
life then moving to Farmer practices
that reduce erosion so farmers use
various techniques to loosen erosion on
their fields one method is intercropping
where different crops are grown together
another approach is crop rotation where
different crops are planted in
alternating Seasons shelter bels involve
planting tall plants to block strong
winds reducing soil movement
conservation is a practice that minimize
the amount of soil turn over during
planting to racing transforms steep
slopes into steps to slow down water
flow and prevent soil wash out Contour
farming is a method where crops are
planted perpendicular to the slope of
Health helping to trap water and prevent
erosion these farming practices help
protect the soil ensuring its long-term
fertility and
sustainability so in summary we have the
intercropping which different crops
mixed together we have crop rotation
which crops are alternate we have
shelter belts that tow plants block wind
we have conservation that soil turnover
is reduced we have ter racing which
steep slopes turned into steps and then
we have Contour forming which planting
perpendicular to Hill
slope then we have ranching practices so
we have ranching is the raising and
grazing of livestock overg grazing
causes and worsen many soil problems
range managers encourage grazing limits
and enforce them on publicly owned land
so we have here overg grazing so compact
soil and damage structure we have
removes native grass and expose bare top
soil then moving here we have that it
allows invasive species to outcompete
Native species because of alternate
environment then we have decreases pores
of
air and decreases pores for water so all
of that will cause to decreases in Grass
growth and survival and leads to wind
and water erosion we are going to talk
about this in detail as we are going to
be creating posters research problems
and connect that to real life
situations